[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARAH GALLOP: Commencement--
one of the most exciting days
of the year.
JOHN MCDONALD:
It's not too often
you have a family member or a
loved one graduating from MIT.
ERIC GRIMSON: It's like inviting
somebody into your home.
You want it to look good.
PING LEE: When the rhododendrons
are blooming, it's beautiful.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[HAMMERING]
MATT MCGANN: It's really
logistically challenging.
TED JOHNSON: We, last
year, had 2856 graduates,
and we presented 2300
pounds of diplomas.
[LAUGHTER]
ERIC GRIMSON: Students
get their diploma,
their piece of history, from
the President or the Provost
on stage.
To make that happen is
an incredible amount
of work behind the scenes.
Our registrar staff is
preparing 2500-plus diplomas
to be in exactly
the right order.
MARY CALLAHAN: We're
very careful and precise,
and it's a team effort
by a group of my staff.
There is a great flux.
Students are hoping
to make their diploma.
Some do, some don't.
So we're continually
monitoring advising students.
ELIZABETH COGLIANO
YOUNG: They line up
according to their degree and
school in alphabetical order.
There are 70 station
aides, and then there's
a team of marshals
that then will
lead each of these specific
groups out to Killian Court.
PRESENTER: Please close
any gaps in the line.
Stay close to the
person in front of you.
PRESENTER: Last name?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PRESENTER: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Li.
PRESENTER: Jessica?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PRESENTER: Thank you.
PRESENTER: Last name?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PRESENTER: Thank you, thank you.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PRESENTER: Uh-huh.
MARY CALLAHAN: They have
to say their last name,
and we'll be checking
at that point
to make sure the student
hasn't dropped inadvertently
out of line or got
lost or something.
PRESENTER: He is absent
but was marked here.
PRESENTER: Yes.
PRESENTER: OK.
MARY CALLAHAN: My office
keeps the master list
of the marching order.
PRESENTER: Right, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Wu.
PRESENTER: Thank you.
Last name?
AUDIENCE: Wu.
PING LEE: There is checks
upon checks upon checks,
because one student gets out
of line, it's a domino effect.
PRESENTER: Jamila S Smith-Dell.
ELIZABETH COGLIANO YOUNG: As
a graduate crosses the stage,
they are handed
their actual diploma.
Whereas many other
schools, they're
mailed their actual
diploma, and they're
handed a fake certificate
at the time of graduation,
we want the students
to actually come off
the stage holding
their actual degree.
[CHEERING]
So it is a very
flexible, dynamic walking
of 2800 people to Killian Court.
MARY CALLAHAN: I've
always felt that for MIT
to do this for their students
says a lot about MIT.
SARAH GALLOP: Yu Hua.
Elliot S Ishmael.
Rachel M Hoffman.
Athena Y Huang.
Lakeisha Jane.
Students will leave me the
pronunciation of their names
on my voicemail.
MAXIMILIANO ZULOAGA (ON
PHONE): Maximiliano Zuloaga.
SARAH GALLOP:
Maximiliano Zuloaga.
Maximiliano Sebastian Zuloaga.
MICHAEL OWU: The real trick is
getting where the emphasis is
in someone's name.
SARAH GALLOP:
Day-miss W Luh-moge.
Luh-moge.
And if you place emphasis
on the wrong syll-a-bull,
then you can really
botch a name.
Andrew J Unander.
[? Jin-wen ?] Wang.
MICHAEL OWU: It's not just the
complexity of an individual's
name, but it's going from a
Chinese name to an Indian name
to an American name
to a German name.
It's that switching
from one language
to the other that can
sometimes be challenging.
PRESENTER: Camille I Henrot.
PRESENTER: Nigamaa Nayakanti.
PRESENTER: Amy S Ishiguro.
MICHAEL OWU: The
ones who know they
have a difficult name, when
you get it right, they smile.
It's a good feeling.
PRESENTER: Nithin Senthur Kumar.
PRESENTER: Marie P [INAUDIBLE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TED JOHNSON: One of the greatest
challenges is the scale.
To set up 14,000 chairs
takes hundreds of people.
NORM MAGNUSON: Basically
what you're doing
is taking Killian Court and
making it into a big stadium.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATT MCGANN: We set up
these great big jumbotrons
PRESENTER: I like to
see a lot of really
happy, waving, smiling,
happy families out there.
PRESENTER: One, pan left,
and go back to the podium.
[INAUDIBLE] one, take one.
MATT MCGANN: For
tens of thousands
of people around
the world who want
to be a part of
this special day,
they can watch this
on the webcast.
PRESENTER: There's waters
and everything inside.
Please have your tickets ready.
Congratulations.
JOHN MCDONALD: We have about
250 volunteers each year
that handle different
functions for our guests--
making sure that they
get into the Court,
having a good place
to sit, having
some information available.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
PRESENTER: Thank you so much.
PING LEE: We are there to
take care of the guests--
make sure they know
where they're going,
they all have water,
they all have programs,
they all have a seat.
TED JOHNSON: We
order bottled water,
probably nearly 20,000 bottles.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
This is New England.
The weather can go
to the extremes.
We have on hand 18,000 ponchos.
They are available
to our graduates too,
and we encourage them to
wear under their gowns.
NORM MAGNUSON: The people
that come from other jobs
because they volunteer to do it,
it's really important to them
that all the chairs
are straight,
that everything looks beautiful.
And I think that it gives them
a sense of serving the students,
and it makes them feel
good about their job.
ELIZABETH COGLIANO
YOUNG: It gives time
to pause and sort of think, wow,
what an amazing place to work,
and how lucky I am to be part
of such a great experience.
PRESENTER: Congratulations.
[CHEERING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]